in uganda running for the presidency
can be a dangerous business
especially if you are 38 year old bobby
wine
the pop star turned politician is the
country's best known opposition leader
and he knows how to work a crowd
but the authorities don't like what this
youthful upstart
has got to say for himself we want to
live in uganda where
we are respected and applaud and not
being known for poverty for disease
for corruption and for dictatorship
that's a uganda that i envision that we
envision
as a generation
bobby wine real name robert chagulani
has made an improbable journey from the
slums
to the main stage and he's harnessed his
fame in aid of a political revolution
[Music]
challenging the 33-year rule of
president
yueri museveni this song called the
ballot
or the bullet and wine knows plenty
about projectiles
campaign stops frequently marked with
tear gas
and rubber bullets although the police
say their measures prevent the spread of
coronavirus
as you can see as you can see this is
how i'm being treated
and the opposition leader has been
detained and arrested
on multiple occasions
i have been targeted by tiago's
canisters and life bullets
every single person that i've been
moving with on the campaign trail has
been
hit and a few days ago my close
journalist was covering the events
around me
in the campaign trail was shot directly
in the head
so wearing a ballistic helmet and a
bulletproof vest
is an effort to secure my life
wisdom is better than strength some
wisdom
president museveni says wisdom is better
than
strength but after five presidential
terms he looks and sounds
like an immovable strong man he did
bring stability
when he took power in 1986 and was
celebrated
at home and abroad but bobby wine's
campaign
has rattled his administration and
scores of younger ugandans
now registering to vote will cast their
ballots
for the insurgent candidate i want
seven to go away then
bob wants to enter wine has plenty of
support
in a country where three quarters of the
population
are under 30 but he's not optimistic
about winning
[Applause]
the election is being stolen
and rigged not will be by the mere
fact that i've been blocked from
campaigns
that my posters are not allowed to be
there that i'm not allowed to have any
billboards
that i'm blocked from radio and tv
stations however
we are going into this election as a
protest
i have been calling upon ugandans to
come out and vote this is our only
opportunity
like much of africa politics in uganda
is
changing even if the governing regime is
not but bobby wine
says time is on his side john sparks
sky news